Transcription: Willow Bushell
Relecteur: eric vautier
Entre vous et moi,
je pourrais me contenter
de vous dire une unique phrase,
un simple conseil
qui finalement ne tient qu’en un mot :
Partez !
Vraiment, partez.
Clair, précis, bien qu’un peu brutal,
je dois vous l’avouer.
Mais est-ce que ça aurait un sens
pour vous si je m’arrêtais à cela ?
Alors restez.
Même si peut-être que certains
d’entre vous ont pensé à se lever
et à sortir de la salle.
Je vous en remercie parce
que je me l’étais imaginé.
Restez, que je donne
un sens à cette phrase.
Je ne sais pas si vous connaissiez
Olivier Folie.
Non, vous non plus.
Je ne le connaissais pas
avant de vous écrire ce discours.
Mais cet inconnu a les mots
que je souhaite vous transmettre.
Il a dit : « Voyager, c’est partir
à la découverte de l’autre.
Le premier inconnu à découvrir,
c’est vous. »
Il y a un an de cela,
je ne m’étais jamais confrontée
à moi-même.
Il y a un an, j’habitais chez mes parents,
j’étudiais et je pensais devenir ingénieur
sur la fabrication de satellites.
Et finalement, aujourd’hui, beaucoup
de ces choses n’ont pas changé.
Premièrement, j’habite
encore chez mes parents
et j’étudie l’ingénierie aérospatiale.
Pourtant j’ai changé.
Pour la première fois de toute ma vie,
je me suis confrontée à moi-même,
je me suis confrontée à l’inconnu
et c’est la raison pour laquelle
je suis là aujourd’hui,
pour vous en parler de mon inconnu.
Alors, il y a un an,
je suis partie à Milan.
Presque exactement un an, d’ailleurs.
J’ai emménagé avec un élève de mon école
que je ne connaissais absolument pas.
Et comme beaucoup d’étudiants,
qui s’en vont vivre à l’étranger,
et d’autant plus comme
tous ces grands enfants comme moi,
qui quittent le domicile familial
pour la première fois de leur vie,
j’ai passé ma première soirée
en Italie à pleurer.
Ce n’est pas très vendeur.
J’aurais pu aller manger
une de ces pizza incroyables.
J’aurais pu faire le tour de la ville,
j’aurais pu aller boire un verre,
mais j’ai pleuré parce que
j’étais tétanisée, j’étais terrifiée.
Parce que l’inconnu est terrifiant.
Et finalement, qui ne l’aurait pas été ?
Mais c'était mon aventure.
Tout était signé.
Tout était loué, préparé.
J’ai regretté mon départ
avant même qu’il ne survienne,
mais je n’avais plus le choix.
Alors je suis partie.
Alors à tous ceux qui pensent à partir
aujourd’hui,
qu’il en aille d’un échange universitaire
ou du Tour de l’Amérique,
avec un sac sur le dos,
ne paniquez pas tout de suite
parce que cette phase assez terrifiante
finalement qu’on vit au début,
elle est très vite remplacée.
Elle est remplacée par la curiosité,
par cet attrait, finalement, de l’inconnu.
Milan, c’était pour moi
un tout nouveau monde.
C’était une nouvelle culture,
c’étaient des dizaines d’opportunités
et c’était la liberté.
J’ai des dizaines d’anecdotes
d’une jeune femme
qui, pour la première fois de sa vie,
vit loin de chez ses parents.
Et il y en a des très drôles.
Mais on n'aura pas le temps
de parler de tout ça.
Alors je vais juste
vous raconter ma préférée.
Ma préférée, c’est ce matin-là,
à la gare centrale de Milan.
Quelques amis et moi avons décidés
de prendre rendez-vous,
mais on n’avait pas destination.
Alors on s’est rejoints dans le grand hall
devant le tableau des départs.
On a regardé et on a choisi le train
le plus intéressant et on est partis.
Alors évidemment, cette liberté me manque.
Mais si je suis là aujourd’hui,
c’est pour vous parler
d’une tout autre liberté.
La liberté d’être, la liberté
de se découvrir et de se redécouvrir.
Parce que là-bas, loin de tout,
vous pouvez être qui vous souhaitez.
Personne ne vous connaît
et tout ce qui vous définissez avant
n’existe pas ici.
Pour ma part, à la fin de cet Erasmus,
avec quelques-uns de mes amis,
on s’est tous acheté un drapeau italien
dans une boutique de souvenirs
un peu trop chère
et on a écrit des mots,
des mots gentils, des souvenirs,
des choses à accrocher
sur le mur de sa chambre en rentrant.
Et sur mon drapeau,
tous les mots ont la même idée.
Cette fille blagueuse,
prête à tout pour une plaisanterie.
Et je ne vous dévoilerai pas
tous les détails de ma vie.
On ne se connaît
que depuis quelques minutes,
Alors j’en ai ri.
J’en ai ri en faisant semblant
de m’en plaindre.
Et à ce moment-là, une de mes amies
a récupéré mon drapeau
et elle y a rajouté une phrase en bas.
Elle a écrit : « Tu construis
ta propre réputation. »
Alors c'était de l'humour, évidemment,
mais elle avait raison.
Là-bas, j’avais décidé de
montrer cette personne
et j’étais devenue cette personne.
J’ai pu vivre un sentiment
assez spécial là-bas
et je vais beaucoup m’ouvrir
à vous aujourd’hui.
Là-bas, loin de mon chez moi,
loin de ma zone de confort habituelle,
je ne me suis jamais sentie aussi
vulnérable de toute ma vie.
Et ce sentiment,
j’ai essayé de le combattre.
J’ai essayé de trouver un nouveau
chez moi, de me sentir
à nouveau sereine.
Pour ça, je me suis
énormément ouverte aux autres,
en espérant qu’à leur tour,
ils s’ouvrent à moi.
Et en plus de me permettre de tisser
des liens extrêmement forts
qui durent encore aujourd’hui,
en m’ouvrant ainsi,
j’ai découvert une nouvelle partie de moi
que je ne connaissais pas avant.
Et c’est cette chose assez incroyable,
cette expérience assez incroyable
que j’ai vécue à Milan :
on ne croisait pas les gens,
on les rencontrait.
Il pouvait s’agir de quelques minutes
à parler d’une spécialité
ou une coutume de leur pays.
Ou une nuit blanche à parler
de rêves, de futur, de croyances.
Chaque personne que j’ai rencontrée
m’a apporté quelque chose.
Et finalement, tout le monde
peut vous apporter quelque chose.
La personne en face de vous,
la prochaine dont vous allez
croiser le regard.
La personne que vous
voyez tous les matins.
Chaque personne vous apporte quelque chose
et vous permettre de vous construire
en tant qu’être humain.
Je vous l’ai dit, j’étais vulnérable.
J'étais loin de cette zone de confort.
J’étais loin de tous ces gens
que j’avais l’habitude de côtoyer,
mon petit confort
dans lequel je m’enfermais.
Et grâce à ça, je me suis découverte.
Et alors,
vous n’avez pas besoin non plus
de partir finalement.
J’ai appris que se découvrir,
ça ne veut pas dire partir sur une île
déserte comme Robinson Crusoé
ou même faire un Erasmus finalement.
En fait, se découvrir, c’est
tous ces petits choix
qui nous éloignent du connu.
Ça peut être cette offre d’emploi
à laquelle vous hésitez à postuler.
Ça peut être cette activité
que vous avez toujours souhaité faire.
Ça peut être cette sortie
à laquelle vous hésitez à aller.
Tout peut changer en un appel.
Et quelles qu’en soient les conséquences,
vous en sortirez différent.
Alors partez,
sortez de cette zone de confort
dans laquelle vous êtes.
Parce que bien plus qu’un impact moral,
tous ces petits choix
impactent sur votre avenir.
Après les quelques minutes
qu’on vient de passer ensemble,
je peux vous l’avouer,
j’abandonne mes satellites.
J’ai eu l’occasion de prendre des cours
d’astrophysique pour la première fois.
Quelque chose dont
je ne connaissais absolument rien.
Mais bon, quitte à partir dans l’inconnu,
j’y suis allée jusqu’au bout
et j’en suis tombée folle amoureuse.
Alors qu’il y a un an,
mon futur me semblait clair et tout tracé,
et bien qu’aujourd’hui il soit
totalement différent,
je n’ai jamais été aussi sûre de moi
et épanouie dans mes choix professionnels.
Et toute cette expérience,
tous ces voyages, tous ces doutes
et même toutes ces leçons
que j’en ai tirées, tout ça
n’a tenu qu’à un.
« Pourquoi pas ? »
C’était une décision rapide,
un dossier à remplir
et me voilà aujourd’hui face à vous,
à essayer de vous convaincre.
Alors qu’avant, j’en avais peur,
aujourd’hui, je ne rêve plus que de ça,
de partir dans l’inconnu.
Et je vous souhaite à tous
de vous y trouver.
Mais ça ne tient qu'à vous.
Alors si mes mots vous parlent,
ignorez toutes les peurs
que vous avez déjà en tête.
Oubliez, abandonnez toutes ces excuses
que vous vous trouvez et partez.
Fuyez cette zone de confort
dans laquelle vous vous terrez.
Partez et, je l’espère pour vous,
revenez différent.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)